Tune in right now!
I don't think they're ready, I don't think they know what they're in for.
Guess what I figured out how to do?
No Muppet, I'm out, good riddance.
If you don't like me at my flesh, my 2D form, you don't deserve my Muppet form.
Hi, my name's C.B. Cottonbump, and I hope you enjoy the stream today.
That's what the megaphone on, though. I can pitch my voice now. Hi.
What's this? Snicks you, grumps you?
Guys, this is a voice reveal, this is my real voice. I'm really sorry. I'm so sorry that I lied to you all these years.
I haven't been around that long, but you know, you get it, but this is me. This is my true self.
But I like how it sounds with the megaphone because I feel like I'm leaving a call.
Like, hey, she can't talk at the phone right now, leave a message after the beep.
Alvin, is that you? I also fixed the peaking, so it shouldn't peak badly.
Mom, I threw up. I need to turn the game sound down for myself. Jesus Christ.
But also... I can't sing. Hold on. Wait, wait, wait.
Jason Derulo. She be Cottonbump.
I'm sorry, I'm a little messing with this so much.
Oh my God. Hold on, let me take that off. All I'm gonna say, I can turn it off.
So there's a giant button that says effects. I didn't know you had to click that in order for the effects to work.
I'm blonde, you see. I'm a little slow, but hopefully the week after next week, I'll try to do a karaoke stream,
because that would be really fun.
Is that mind activated? No. Oh wait, wait, wait, watch.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Oh, but now I can, now I can raise you guys up in a dude voice.
Hey, baby girl, what's going on? You wanna come back to my crew later?
I sound like the trivia murderer, but oh my God, you're right.
Now everybody, look at your cards. If you don't, you're going to die.
What's up? My name's Shabroni. I'm an F-boy.
I've been on Love Island, too hot to handle all those shows.
You sound like a guy who has a leftist mother's basement.
Boy, Serpiel, this is me. This is where I really am.
What's that, what's that corp song go like?
Choke me like you hate me, but you love me.
Loki, you wanna date me when you fuck me?
Are you rizzed? Are you feeling rizzed?
And then I can, I can, I just sound weird when it's high pitched.
If I go higher, it sounds even weirder if I do my Ooloo voice with it.
It kind of sounds really cute though, like hi, my name's Shabby Cottonbum.
I know, the voice changes, what do you mean?
I'm going to stomp on you and crush you and then I'm going to beat you up
and you're not going to be able to do anything about it.
How does it feel to be beat up by a younger woman?
Like, yeah, she's trying to sound like Emmy.
Um, if I, if I listened to Emmy's voice, I could probably, oh.
Actually, I sound kind of hot when I use my deeper mommy voice with this.
Hi, how's it going?
If I listened to Emmy's voice, I could probably do it without a voice changer.
Holy crap, I sound like really hot like this, what the hell?
Um, dude, what the hell, I wish this was my normal voice.
Oh, um, it's a combination of my Patreon voice.
Hi, sweetie, how are you doing sweetheart?
Are you behaving like Tara Reid?
Oh my god, this is intense.
Are you blushing?
Oh sweetie, you don't have to blush with me.
Now give us the Patreon voice with a deep voice.
Okay, hold on, hold on, hold on.
Hi honey.
What's the matter sweetheart?
Cat got your tongue?
Is there a problem here, officer?
Aren't I just the woman of your dreams?
Isn't there anything I could do to get out of this ticket?
What?
Um, anyways, I sound like I smoke too many cigarettes.
Oh, what if I sound British when I do this?
Hi, sweetheart, how are you doing?
Oh god, oh no, I don't, guys, I think, I think I'm too hot with this voice.
Oh no, oh my god, I'm actually blushing at my own voice, holy crap.
Oh no, she's hot.
Um, is it obvious that my voice is pitched when you hear it?
Or is it not too obvious?
I can't tell because I can hear my normal voice and then, um, I can hear the other voice.
It sounds a bit pitched, okay.
The roleplay streams are about to go crazy, sweetheart.
Hee hee hoo hoo, I am gonna stomp on you.
Yeah, there's a bit of digital noise.
I can kind of hear that too.
Oh!
Let me see, hold on, hold on, hold on.
Hold on, if I talk deeply, it kind of gets back.
The narrow, what's a narrow pitch?
Narrow, whoa, what the hell?
Holy, what does the gender mean?
What is, there's no, why is there a gender thing?
Medium, wide, wide, wide?
Whoa, okay, and I didn't really do anything.
Whoa, what the, huh?
Oh my god, that's terrifying.
Um, hold on, um, what's the, what is, this is like hard tune on my voice, I think.
This just makes me sound really weird.
Uh, oh, hello, I'm so deep voiced.
Who's the Dommie Mommy now?
Tron?
Like, I'm from Tron.
Speak like a sim with that voice.
Maybe just had a Robo Gas.
Okay, let me take that off.
Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh.
Okay, I took off, hold on, hold on, and then if I add the pitch a little bit, what if I do it like this?
Uh, uh, I like my beats fast and my bass.
Wait, I don't know how to voice.
Awkward, I'm like why is my voice so high, I sound like Alvin.
Why do you meet?
Christmas, Christmas time is here
Time for fun and time for cheer
And I gotta hope I hope
Ahhhh
Ah
Me, I wanna hope
This is great
I'm having the time of my life, you have no idea.
And I discovered this like five minutes before stream started and I'm like, are you serious?
It was this simple?
I accidentally bumped the FX button and then it immediately changed my pitch and I'm like,
what the heck's going on?
Oh my god, oh my god.
I don't know why it has that little like robot pitch though.
If I put that, that's why I like the megaphone because you can't tell whether the drill thing is there.
So it just sounds, it's not as obvious.
I like the hard tune because then I sound like Jason to roll out, guys.
The next viewer telling me it's gonna be wild.
Which voice is Muppet?
Shebe's cannon voice?
Well, that's just, hi, how's it going?
Hi.
I sound like Alistair.
I never watched Hasbin Hotel.
Is it good?
And sometimes I stay away from stuff because of the crazy fan bases.
British Muppet?
No, I'm not a British Muppet.
When I'm in my Muppet form, she'd be Muppet.
When I'm Shebuppet, I need to think of a better name.
I'm so sorry I burped in autotune.
Muppet voice with the pitch voice.
Oh, hold on.
I got you.
Hold on.
Hi, how's it going?
Oh no, I don't like this at all.
I just sound like Anna Farris or something.
Wait a second.
I almost sound like Niana's.
Hi.
What the hell?
What the fuck?
No, her voice isn't that high.
I bet I can.
Hi, can I sound like her like this?
I'm trying to work on my impressions.
I've been inspired by one of the new talents from...
I need to work on it.
Pitch down Muppet voice.
Whoa.
Hey, how's it going?
I don't think I like this that much.
It's really hard to do.
It sounds really weird.
I kind of sound like Azura.
I think I have to be listening to people's voices so I can do an impression.
Run, run, run, run.
Hold on.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Falco punch.
Sorry.
Maelind Street.
Maelind Street, Maelind Street, Maelind Street.
Holy crap.
Holy crap, everybody.
It's not the drill.
I got it.
I think.
This would be good.
For ASMR.
Welcome to Shibi's ASMR.
The reverb, yeah, I have the echo on.
This is reverb.
I'll do the reverb.
I'm wishing, I'm wishing for the one I love to find me, to find me today.
I was thinking something like T-Pain, wait what's a T-Pain song, hold on, hold on, hold
on, it's five o'clock, wait, no.
I don't know why I'm blanking on T-Pain songs, I don't know why I'm blanking on T-Pain songs.
I'mma buy you a drink, ooey, I'mma take you home with me, got money in my bag.
I don't know why I'm blanking on T-Pain songs.
Give me a nice Mimi song.
Take a girl out to dinner first, won't you?
I don't know why I'm blanking on T-Pain songs.
I'm blanking on T-Pain songs.
I know why I'm blanking on T-Pain songs.
I don't know why I'm blanking on T-Pain songs.
I'm blanking on T-Pain songs.
Fuck.
Huh.
I'm blanking on T-Pain songs.
I don't know why I'm blanking on T-Pain songs.
Why am I going so fast?
I don't know what just happened there.
I don't know why I'm blanking on T-Pain songs.
I'm blanking on T-Pain songs.
I'm going to fight myself.